this program
features live coverage of an african
safari and may include animal kills and
carcasses
viewer discretion is advised
good afternoon everybody welcome to juma
in the sarby sands in south africa where
we have found a beautiful european
roller perched
beautifully on the end or the top of a
termite mound
it's looking such nice colors today
very fresh blue [ __ ] seams some
beautiful blues
really really interesting to see it is a
wonderful 33
or 34 degrees fahrenheit 34 degrees
celsius
94 degrees fahrenheit and probably about
200 percent
humidity it is unbelievably sticky this
afternoon
as the bird is now opened its beak to do
some
gala fluttering to cool itself down no
doubt in anticipation for some termite
aled's to be coming out of the termite
mound so it can pick up some bulk
and with its new plumage in readiness
for migrating
back up to sort of eastern central
europe
good afternoon everybody my name is
steve joined by become camera don't
forget we are interactive we'd love to
hear from you
hashtag safarilive or throw your
questions in on youtube chat stream
don't forget the all-important at fc
should we have another look at this bird
it's not often we get to see
the european roller sitting like that on
the end of a terma mount normally we
find these birds perched
on the top of a dead tree they are
insect eaters
and the european roller is silent in
africa oh off it's gone
and off it goes beautiful it is very
very sticky this afternoon everybody and
we had a deluge
last night of rain that came down and
covered the landscape
wiping the carpet or the ground
wiping the ground fresh and clean
for any new tracks so we're going to see
what we can find this afternoon i would
love to see if we can find chidulu of
course
with her cubs but it might be a little
bit too early in the afternoon
but anyway we're going to go around and
see what tracks they might be heading
into that direction
because it wouldn't it be wonderful i
had some fresh tracks of her yesterday
but after this rain all the old tracks
are gone and all that will be there
are fresh activities so maybe she's
coming in and out again
and go and have a look let's go and have
a look we'll do a big sort of loop
around that block
and see what has happened um there's
been no reports of fukumori leaving the
property
i have a feeling he's on a kill
somewhere inside our property we just
haven't
really found him so that could be the
chance or opportunity for this afternoon
follow up on hukumuri follow up on
chidulu and see if we can find
any hokudulus wouldn't that be awesome i
know all of you back home
are sort of um choking it a bit to see
some new leopard cubs
and well i hope we can provide them for
you but the rains that we had
came down with enormous lightning storms
seemingly hitting the roof around where
i was look where i was sleeping last
night woke me up at about half past two
wow it was frightening i don't normally
get
i don't normally get afraid of lightning
but it honestly felt like the lightning
bolts were hitting the building
so i just unplugged everything that i
had and uh climbed up to my bed and
hopefully we didn't
well i didn't die i'm here
but it is added to an enormous amount of
humidity that is
a thick fog blanket of moisture in the
air
well
yes nina i can hear you there that's the
first
i can hear you so on we go
i'm going to check sort of our south
western section of the
of the property to see what has been
coming and going
some nice elephant tracks in the road
it's a good day for ellies
we'll go straight down this road this is
zoe's this is where we've got our
initial
tracks of chadulu and her cubs heading
straight down towards where
they are potentially denning those of
you who
aren't sure what's been going on
chadoulou piers has come back onto juma
with her two cubs we haven't seen them
yet but we did see her yesterday morning
so i'm making it my mission to try and
show
them to you
i'm sorry i actually have no idea we
don't keep our own records
um so it's hard to say i know that last
week
we probably got about 72 mills uh that's
one of the landowners told me he'd
measured it on his property up in
buffalo
and last night it came down i mean you
can see the road in front of us has been
washed
enormous amounts of erosion has happened
erosion for those of you who are not
sure what that means is the movement of
a sediment from one place to another
so erosion is all of this movement of
the road sort of sediment and
a lot of it coming off from the side of
the roads as well in something called
sheet erosion which is a really big
problem due to overgrazing
so too many animals in an area losing
ground cover leads to sheet erosion
which eventually leads to very very
unmanageable areas when the sheets
erosion turns into gully donga
and erosion that then becomes almost
impossible to fix without serious
management
intervention so the nice slow
patterning rain that soaks in to the
ground
is always the best well it seems like
sydney who spent a lot of time this
morning trying to find the lions has
managed to relocate on them again this
afternoon
next to the border between joomla game
reserve and the buffers work
a very very good afternoon and most of
all welcome to the spectacular sighting
i am traveling with senzu who is my
camera
operator this afternoon and for in case
if you need our attention
we are highly available you can follow
us on twitter
safarilive you can also follow us
on youtube chat stream
so i just want to count because this
morning it was very difficult for me to
count them
look at that this is an amazing
experience
one two three four
five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
so let me just repeat that just to make
sure one two
three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven yes they
are eleven at the moment it's quite a
very big pride
and this is the pride we normally see as
a result
of the presence of buffalos but
unfortunately i haven't seen the
buffalos for quite a while
the last time i have seen the buffaloes
it was just the tracks
and that was about three days ago if not
four days ago
somewhere around the sandy page area
there were some fresh treks of buffaloes
the day we saw the mating youngest
unkuhuma female
with one of the avocados
so you can see that now it's time for
them to rest but it's difficult at the
moment for me
to judge where they're gonna go for a
drink afterwards because
here where we are it's not very far away
from sydney's damn
it's just about a few minutes away and
the galagopine is on a distance
unless they've got a mission of going to
do some hunt
much more towards the galagopine area
i'll be here
for the whole day to try and see what
their intentions are
what their intentions are by looking at
the stomach i can tell that
they're not very hungry but lions are so
very opportunistic
while walking down to the waterholes
they can show
us some of their hunting skills
i have seen a white lion before not once
not twice
the white lions they are completely
different from
what we are seeing now in terms of the
color and what
causes the white lines is a phenomenon
called leucism lysism is whereby
the melanistic pigment is not very there
and as a result the color of the body
turns white
which is not nice for a wild animal
because
when it comes to hunting they can easily
get spotted
so mostly the white lions do depend on
these ones
when they're going out for hunting
uh john i am not seeing the lioness you
are referring to
if you can just repeat that but what i
can promise you is that there is quite a
lot of fightings
amongst the big cats such as the lions
and leopards so their fightings can be
so very much vicious
they do get injured sometimes during the
fighting for food
and sometimes when fighting the other
females who are trying to enter into
their territories they can be very much
protective too
not only the males are protective so by
these territorial animals
females as well they do fight against
other animals of the same sex
so it's time now for some of them to
groom themselves you can see we've got
this one in front and the other one in
the back is also lifting up
his leg there so this is very normal
lions they do spend much of their time
just grooming
trying to get rid of the parasites and
also trying to
take off some of the debris or the dead
hairs
from the body
so you can see that this area is so very
much quiet
they're not making any noise so
sometimes if the wind is from their
favor
it's very easy for a prey animal to bump
onto them
so what i like about the lions is when
they wake up
afterwards you will see maybe that is
going to happen while we're still here
they normally go and isolate themselves
from the group and start defecating
and urinating so they go just
to defecate when they wake up all the
time and after that is when you see them
starting to do like this they will go
and do
some scratching you'll see them even
holding branches from the trees like
this
when they're doing some stretching when
they are
now becoming active preparing in order
to walk long distances or going
for hunting activities
so look at that pole so you can see this
is what we see
on the ground so it's just that it's not
showing us the underneath paths
nicely so this is
how the domestic cats as well do clean
themselves
so they lick the front legs and clean
the face
so you can see that other one is now
busy doing some cleaning normally they
do like this
early in the mornings now i want us to
see what steve is looking for while i'm
still waiting
to see if these lions are going to
entertain us more this afternoon
hello everyone we've stopped at a
termite mound that was
flourishing with birds a moment ago and
now they've all gone all of our swifts
and swallows were flying and
bombing this um there's still a few
coming around bombing this termite mound
that probably had some flying termites
elates coming out
as their european roller was doing
before uh you get sort of
bursts of energy or bursts of of
individuals coming out
after the rain that's when a lot of
reproductives will come out when the
ground is nice and soft
and then they can go and do their new
colonies but the birds take huge
advantage of it and we had
probably 50 odd birds a moment ago just
sort of dive bombing this term up mount
but you get moments of lots of alerts
coming out and then obviously they start
dying down as their numbers dwindle
anyway they'll continue on
there's a lot of birds with forktail
drongos as well as blackheaded orioles
all going absolutely crazy for the
termites
although we couldn't actually even see
any but the birds were showing us that's
definitely something was going on
okay so we're still carrying on down
this road um the ground is
very nice for tracking on this road
particularly because it's nice and soft
cat lady we work all day every day we
never stop and never have a breather
don't eat lunch breakfast or dinner
we're just constantly
working no i'm joking um well we we
present in the morning in the afternoon
so that's six hours
but half an hour either side of that for
preparation on the vehicle
and then there's always different
reviews on a friday these days we're
doing a
a half an hour to an hour review on the
week
but when there's tv shows there's a lot
more extra effort that goes in
uh for example the sabc there's an extra
hour or so
each day uh for that for the show and
then there's also an extra hour the next
day for a review
uh there's a morning meeting every
morning which takes up between
10 and half of 10 minutes and half an
hour
there's also vehicle maintenance on
wednesdays that we do cleaning
and that can take anywhere from 20
minutes to an hour as well
and then obviously as the presenters and
guides we are constantly learning
constantly refreshing our brains and
learning new techniques and strategies
and
information so as to impart it on you
lovely people back home
so we should never stop working but we
need time in the day to reflect on
ourselves
uh we exercise while most of us do get
some exercise in
we definitely have to make time for
eating and uh well
socializing as well in the evening of
course it's just a little bit of
sitting around and chatting i wouldn't
call that work but we live here
so we can't we pretty much on call if
that makes any sense it's not like
people who can have
a nine to five then they go home then
they got free to themselves
there could be anything going on in an
evening but invariably most evenings are
our own
and most the time during the day is our
own time as well but
that is not always the case
hope that answers your question
but in the guiding industry you guide
all the time you're constantly busy
zen you want to know where this is being
filmed well we are in juma in the sarby
sands which is on the north
eastern side of south africa between
mozambique
and well six hours from johannesburg six
and a half hours east
of johannesburg in a vehicle our
hour so if you fly not very far
so the greater kruger national park okay
so just having a look some tracks of
some in pilot have been running over
here i'll just show you back there
it's possible that they've been fighting
though
there we go you can see these tracks
over here
of a male impala very dug in in the
ground it looks like they're
probably either running or there's a
little bit of fighting going on between
two males but anyway from our very nice
impala tracks in the sand let's go over
to cauli who's found
a much bigger antelope
good afternoon and welcome again to
sunset safari we are here with this
beautiful
water box we can see the male day
far end and the youngsters all over the
place we have the female youngsters
and the male youngsters my name is oli
and joining me behind the camera is
uncle james we are in chittor
that's chidor dam right here that there
so for any questions or comments you can
catch us on hashtag follow on twitter or
youtube chat stream
what's happening here it's so amazing
because we have this
little ones right here sitting and
chilling
and you can see they're chewing their
cut and these ones here the females
see they don't have horns
oh they're they're fighting they're on
top uncle james look there look
oh that male is chasing that female i'm
sure
he wants to mate and that one that
female there it's still young
i'm sure he's trying to
tell him to tell her
something about mating or something or
or move away from him
so what's happening here it's so amazing
because we have two
um adult male water parks
and last time i checked the water parks
they
have territories around water holes
and so i think these ones are the
testosterone levels are low
that's why they tolerate each other but
sometimes they can
tolerate other males
from different territories when
they are here to drink water or to
to to graze around and they go back to
your territories
and you can see this is a full grown
male
teaching his his tail there
chasing away the flies and insects
it's hot today you can see these young
chips
are in the shade
there's not a lot going on right here so
that's why i will
drive to cheat with them
rosalind how far can
how fast can um the water park run
remember water parks they're
they're big you can say
animals and they can reach up to the
speed of 60
to 275 kilometers per hour
they're not fast as a thomson's gazelles
but they are quick enough to
outrun a predator
you can see they are looking in
different directions because they have
to
be safe at all times and more especially
next to a demo waterhole
everyone likes to drink and then they
are looking out for
predators and if they spot one they will
alum
and they will take off
oh heapers are shouting at me
kimberly you want to know how often to
do these guys
mate uh
as you can see now we have a lot of
youngsters over here
these youngsters they are more or less
the same age it means they
they love mating or they they would mate
just right at the beginning of the
of the dry seasons so that they can
they can give birth around the wet
season
that's what they normally do you can see
these youngsters these young chips they
have
their males there their horns are
it just came out not long ago
and it seems like they uh they've
they're staying far apart from each
other and if you can check those are
the only young males and these ones on
here the only
females young females
so they need to have some gail's chat
and some boys chat
so i'm at chitwa damn
i'll be going to check what's happening
there so for now let's go to sydney with
the animals that will love to eat
the water park
we are still here enjoying uh the
umkuhumas who are still now in bed
they are not showing any sign of doing
something at the moment they're all we
have seen is them battling with flies
as some of them we can see they've got
some small wounds
maybe it's as a result of moving in
between the branches when chasing
some prey animals to feed and their
flies are just
everywhere
so you can see they're not enjoying
their sleep
there's a big difference between the dry
season and the rainy season
rainy season has got quite a lot of
insects active and
flies are some of those
you can see that one has got quite a lot
of flies and is the one who's battling
the most
even trying to vibrate the skin there
you can see all the time to chase those
flies
but it looks like those flies are not
listening
gizmo the lions they do sometimes
uh secrete a very distinctive smell um
normally after the rain
like now we are here if it rains anytime
from now
we know that when they wet the smell is
going to be different
but there's there's their scent is not
bad it is something that
we can tolerate it's not something that
is going to it's going to make me
leave the sighting because of any
suffocation no
so they do yes smell bad because
of the water
so sometimes yes after feeding on
carry-ons remember
lions they do eat fresh meat yes they
hunt but sometimes they also scavenge
and they eat carry-ons
they also eat rotten meat after feeding
on rotten meat
the smell is going to be different and
that is the smell which
maybe i can say it can be very much bad
i
have experienced it before not once and
not twice
so these animals when a big animal such
as an elephant is dead
they can even go deep in the stomach
safari sorry is quite very difficult for
the wound to get the markets because
these kind of animals they do look after
themselves and every time what makes the
wound to take
time to reheal is the following safari
sally
when these kind of animals has got a
wound
they have got to lick it all the time
and when they are licking it is when
they are cleaning it and that also makes
it difficult
for the wound to to recover very quickly
because they the tongue of the lion
is course and because of that when
they're leaking
they are taking off the dead tissues and
when the
wound is trying to recover they can open
it time again and again
now you can see the wound there look at
those flies there is quite a lot of
flies
right on top there
so you can see that that lion is not
even above that
anymore because he has been having that
wound for quite a long time
so i have been seeing this wound since i
have arrived here in juma
i think it is an old injury
uh becky i'm trying to check here you
know the easiest way for me
to recognize the manganese boy is to
check the tail
i can see i think that one day senzo
the one which is facing the other side
the opposite side
that one must be the manganese male
because the manganese male
lost the tassel of the tail you know the
lions are the only cats amongst the big
amongst the kids
who's got a tassel at the tip of the
tail
so the manganese males as a result of
mange
they have lost that tassel let's look at
that
so i cannot see that very well but i can
see that the tussle there
is not highly developed so i am
suspecting
that that lion we are seeing there with
that very beautiful tale must be the
mangani
as the mangani meals are also recovering
from mains
at the moment they are getting much
better
so mange is not something good to have
because it is a contagious disease
which can is which can get transmitted
from
one animal to the other especially when
animals are sharing food together
when animals are sharing the same
shelter and sharing
the breath as well so it can also pose
danger
so i don't know if maybe in a very short
space we will start to see
some developments on this one or maybe
they will survive it
so the way these lions are sleeping you
can see that they are so confident
that nothing can predate them none of
them
is on a watch out
uh brand that is quite a very
interesting question
what i must tell you now with regards to
that is that
to be a cub whether it's from a lion or
from a leopard
it is not easy it's a very difficult
stage of life
these animals when they are like this
now
at the ages we are seeing them they have
survived danger
when the lions has got cubs the biggest
threat first is
the other male lions from the
neighboring territories to come over
trying to take over the the pride or
trying to take over
the territory they can infanticize the
little ones
and apart from that the lions when
they're
left behind hiding by the hidden places
the wild dogs and other predators such
as highness
can also kill them say the competition
is too high
lions has also got a problem when it
comes to
teething during the development of teeth
they do
experience severe pains and some of
these animals
because of the severe pains they do lose
their lives
something else which can be a stretch is
what is called
a failure in feticide failure
in fantasize is kind of an infanticide
which is conducted
by the females themselves when the
females
has done a diagnostic assessment and see
that
the little one is not going to make it
because of diseases
or because of the bad condition they can
be able
to kill their own carbs themselves
okay
so now let's go to tully coley has got
one of the biggest predators
i can say he's jogging or he's swimming
around to
get fit or to check what's happening
around here
so what's happening here is this
beautiful crocodile you can
see right over here you can only see the
upper part
you can see the spike like things
and these things are so strong
you see the
the eyes sorry
and during this time you can see the the
way
that this dam is just drying slowly and
surely
and then there will be hunting for fish
they can find fish in this pan or in
this dam
and they can they store food if they
have a big meal
they will store food in their tails so
when the food
get lesser and lesser they will start
utilizing the food the food or the
nutrients that they'll find from
the tail you can see right over there
the water is getting shallow and shallow
so crocodiles are known to travel long
distances
from a water hole to another water hole
when it gets
dry they tolerate each other around the
water holes
but when it gets dry and dry that's
where the conflict
starts
submerged it's coming up now
and these are the beautiful biggest wrap
tiles you can find
here the second largest is
it's a water monitor
let's listen to the sounds of the world
from the hippos day
the birds
we have the spoon peel there have never
had a spoonful making a call
i'd love to hear a spoonful making a
call
i saw something interesting about a
spoonfield yesterday
it was hunting but walking in the water
and it was submerging its head
in the water it was my first time seeing
such a behavior
so it was very hungry do i need to see
through the water
we have our famous spirit oh and the
little ones there
ravinder you want to know are there any
baby crocs in the
in this river that one i'm not sure
whether
are any youngsters here but sometime
last month
i spotted one small croc
so i don't know whether there's still
any young ones
but let's hope we'll see the youngsters
you know it's so
nice to see the youngsters all the time
yeah we have this beautiful bird right
there
for ratcheting and around and and fixing
the nest you can see that
bird is called a red big
buffalo weaver
they utilize this nest if you see this
huge
nest on top of a tree or a dead tree or
maybe in total for
an anthena these network
aerials long ones you find the most
most of them they have the this huge
nest
and these nests they belong to the red
big
buffalo weavers
and there's a cheat to achieve our
reserve there
i'm sure they having a very nice view
oh we have ourselves
a terrapin
so i've seen a biggest
terrapin on my way to chitwa but i
didn't have a nice view there
so for now let's go to steve he has some
fresh
cat's tracks
welcome back everybody well we've come
around on to triple m the main boundary
on the western side and
well you can clearly see in the muddy
ground over here
a leopard track a beautiful beautiful
leopard track
and she's so tempted to take a mold of
this but
the sad part about this track is is if
we go back
a few meters and um
what's happened over here is here are
the two cubs
two tracks of the cubs in the mud and
they've gone across
and down and west into arithusa i think
and if you just scan the vegetation here
bk you'll see how much rain
fell and apparently the cubs with mum
were just upstream
over here so no doubt with the amount of
rain that fell last night it would have
encouraged her to probably move the cubs
to
an area that was maybe a little bit
drier unfortunately they have now gone
straight across here
and seemingly all the tracks come here
just there in the mud
just there and then they follow her
across into
arithus i'm just gonna have one more
little look but it definitely seems as
if
they have gone directly out yeah
back into the drainage system just on
the other side of the road which is
sorry about the ariel there which is out
of our area unfortunately
well that's disappointing but at least
we know that they've crossed but there's
always a good opportunity that she might
come back again
in the coming weeks but for now probably
with the rain that felt she decided let
me move them
you know being in a dry river bed when
rain falls like that is um
well instinctively most animals know
you've got to get out and go somewhere
where the ground is a bit drier
don't want to drown okay so at least we
know
they have crushed again but there's
nothing stopping them from jumping back
in again we're going to keep our eyes
and ears
on the ground for that to happen but for
now unfortunately folks the hukudulus
have
seemingly gone west
so on we go we're gonna go do a little
bit of a water point patrol
uh there's a really nice sort of breeze
picked up now which is cooling things
down
quite nicely which i'm quite happy about
come in on our fire break road
and we're right in the south western
corner
the big junction over here indicates all
the other properties
becky are you asking where is tingy i
have no idea where tengana is
i haven't seen him since last week's
sunday so
he we haven't even heard any reports of
him in the north uh but the buffalo suk
landowners have been
pretty short supply they haven't been
many of them around
so they haven't been covering buffalo
stock probably as much as they'd like to
and uh we also haven't had the juma
guards in attendance for a couple of
days
so i'm sure he's around somewhere but
he's probably in the north
um the last we had of him was tracks
going north and he's probably up there
probably on a kill sometimes they can be
on a kill for a couple of days and then
you don't see their tracks
and if you're not covering that area
well you won't see him come out we cover
our property quite deliberately every
day
we really do drive around and check for
tracks but if a leopard just happened to
cross there on a little bit
a little bit of a harder or grassy patch
on the road
very hard to see it could be right there
on a kill somewhere nearby just in the
north
but we just don't know anyway we're
going to continue on down
this lovely road which is going to take
us
to the hyena den and while we're just
gonna have a pop
pop our nose in there and see what
they're doing because there seems to be
a little bit of sort of cloud
developing down in the south which is
sort of obscuring the sun which is
keeping it
a little bit more cool but hopefully the
lions will get up shortly and start
moving because well they don't do
too much when it's very hot
we are still here with the lions and
they are still lying down just like a
carpet
and i am so fascinated by this one here
look at this freeway lion is just lying
down
and having his legs on top of the other
and the other one is not even worried
so when these animals are so lying down
close to each other it helps to insulate
them
when it's too cold but now it's very hot
and look at that one is doing
so this is a sign that animals such as
lions they've got a very strong social
bonds
apart from that one there's even another
one there
is also doing more or less the same i'm
going to show you now
look at that so you can see that these
animals don't have
problems uh with each other and when
they wake up later on you see them
even grooming each other that is a sign
of a good social uh structure
these animals by leaking each other and
cleaning each other or grooming each
other
it helps in order to maintain their
relationship so we have not seen
any of the big males here but uh yeah
obviously
that manganese is one of the mangani
males
so this is showing you that yes the
pride of lions
normally the females spend much of their
time just by themselves
and the males can be very much nomadic
and come back here
when the female is on heat
they serve others they've got to learn
how to hunt
remember hunting is part of their
survival
so these animals when they are less than
a year old
it is too risky and dangerous for the
little ones
to accompany the adults and participate
on hunting activities
but once they become 16 to
20 months two years in full is when they
start
to learn how to be independent
so they learn how to hunt when they're
about 18 years
so that is when they can be able to do
hunt in full by themselves
but when they're younger than that the
chances of them to take down something
is very much low and again they can
spoil
the chances of the well-experienced
lions here
to take down a prey
uh i i didn't get that question very
well if you can repeat that look at that
that is the pole that is what we see on
the ground when we are checking
this is what we look for you can see the
three loops there nicely
this is confirming this is a catch as
the dogs has got two loops
and the cut has got three lobes look at
those beautiful
toes there and they have got some claw
sheath
which is right here after this toes
which helps them
when they are feeding
uh macy unfortunately here by the lions
when they're sleeping
they're all lied down so lions don't
worry too much
about the other animals coming to
predate them
they've got good sense of smell and good
hearing ability
so when they're lying down like this you
must know they don't have
any of them who is on a watch out or on
a lookout
but when they've got a kill is well they
must have to guard
against the kill the behavior is
different when they've got a kill
from when they just hide when they're
just
lying down relax like we are we are
seeing now so now
let's cross over to my other friend
this guy is looking afraid
you can see his eyes are wide open
we are so lucky to see such
animals during daytime because around
this time they like
to hide and they create
these nests that are called a form
in a thicket they will stay there until
it gets dark
so now it saw an opportunity
to come out and feed i think he it
didn't fit enough last night you can see
it's his nose is
getting his information from
from the a
and
you see the eyes are huge
this men save good eyesight
and they are chewing feeding they and
remember they can also
feed on their droppings because their
digestive system is not
as great as other animals
and the ears are wide open because he
knows that
eagles small cats big cats
they might hunt for for him
and i remember when i was still a boy
very hungry i used to
have a dog and we used to go out with my
friends
to to hunt these things
what happened was they have this
survival strategy or strategy that they
they do when it comes to predation
because they are most they must live in
pearson you can find them in pairs you
can find them singly
but when they're in pairs and they're
being chased by a dog
one will will stay there and hide and
one will take off
then the dog will go for that one that
took off and when it gets tired
it will go to the very same spot where
the wine is hiding then the one that was
hiding it will take off and this other
one will
will rest there until the one gets tired
and those are the things you we
i had to land while i was still a point
hunting these things
you can see where he is right now it's
well camouflaged you can say that but
a bird of prey can spot it easily
yes so let me leave this guy because
he's
not comfortable here let's go to steve
with the hyena
welcome back everyone well we've come
down to the
hyena den and there was no one in
attendance but we
came around the corner and we found one
individual i think it's june
in the mud wallows on the other side of
the road but she's got a bit of a limp
to her
and she's gonna go to the den site which
is exciting there's a little bit of
cloud cover as i suggested before
she was in the shade of that tree in
another mud walla where we often find
buffalo
and um she's been very very
she's very saturated but she's now going
straight back to the den so
i think maybe we will follow her because
if she does go to the den sorry she's
going behind the car how rude she is
june we parked so lovely here so that
she would drive in front of us
walk in front of us and then we could
show everybody
so june is the hardest of the ladies to
sort of identify
because she doesn't have too much of a
spot pattern on the right hand side
and the left hand's uh left hand side
she doesn't have much of a spot pattern
but the right hand side is jamie
suggests you're looking for
the word juice that comes out and
well that is now now that jamie's
explained it to us all so well like that
it's impossible not to see but the other
side of her there's nothing
she's going oh oh we just drove through
something that was june
june left something there for us whoo
she's going straight to the den site
which is very positive because um she'll
make a noise and her little youngsters
will probably come say mama
we want to eat we want to suckle which
is
very exciting we're just pulling in now
everybody
hold on to your horses june please don't
drop one of those again that was really
really bad beacon are both sort of
caught ourselves there
okay so she's just popping up onto the
dance site over here she's going to go
to the shaded east wing
which is the favorite side when it's
nice and warm
and let's see if there's going to be any
babies that are going to come out i'm
certain it's june due to the fact that
she's got the non-descript
spots and um she's got two very intact
ears okay but she looks like she's got a
bit of a bit of a lump everybody
got a bit of a limp enlarged mammary
glands
yes
a little bit of a cut on the top of her
right ear now
so i don't know what's going on but
maybe where are your babies are they
going to come out and suckle
everyone's hoping they will they're
looking inside she's not making any
noises
they often make a noise when they want
their youngsters to come and suckle
and i wonder why she didn't take her
kids to the swimming pool with her
maybe she oh there they are i think she
needed some me time
somehow some june time everybody here
they come and there's blanc i think
that's blanc
here they come they can't help
themselves
they're all smelling here as well again
june what did you do
there's something very smelly about you
this morning this afternoon
okay so it's not blanc it's uh pretty's
two youngsters that have now popped
out and they are always a lot of fun
they like to smell my shoe and trisha's
shoe i suppose they like to smell
everybody's shoe
why are you guys going to that side of
the mound that is the north wing that is
where it's normally quite
warm maybe june wants a little bit of
privacy
oh and here comes a third so the plonk
is definitely among them i'm just going
to try to figure out which one is he
he's he's a little bit darker than the
other two i've found
his spot pattern he's also quite
inquisitive
don't forget folks we are interactive
would love to hear from you hashtag
throw them in on the youtube chat stream
hello you're coming out very tentatively
there little one
one of the adults is back kids can come
out and play
precious very precious okay well here
comes in
one of the inquisitive ones all sorts of
smells coming from our vehicle
but for the moment june is the one with
all the smells that they're interested
in
everyone's excited to see the clan we
are indeed as well
it's early in the afternoon for them to
be coming out but there's a really big
system building
sort of in the south over there bk if
you want to just show them that system
building
which has obliterated the sun
look at all of that it's hidden the sun
from view
and has dropped the temperature
dramatically
and well we're going to be watching that
very closely
jennifer sizes in hyenas comes from male
and female
generally a male or of a female is
generally a little bit bigger than a
male
um but especially a matriarchal female
is bigger as well due to sort of
testosterone
imparted on the youngster while in the
womb
i think that one is plonk on the left
he's got a few more dark spots
so there is just a sexual dimorphism
between hyenas in general
and so generally the females are bigger
than males
um but a dominant female is generally
even bigger so
than others males are generally much
smaller
but these three look very similar in
size at the moment and it's very
difficult really to tell them apart
i haven't quite figured out their spot
pattern yet so i do apologize
but i think plonk is the darker of the
three when it comes to spots
that one's quite pale the one in the
front
is also quite pale bk and the one
sitting in the back looking at us
longingly
has got a few darker spots and i thought
that was plonk
because i've seen him suckling corky a
few times
debbie i'm not sure if she's been seen i
mean this is
the second third time fourth time that
her cubs have been seen here at the den
but i'm not aware of where pretty's been
um
i haven't heard of her being seen um
trish never mentioned seeing her the
last time and
i think james and paulie have had bad
luck every time they've come here sydney
has certainly been seeing them i don't
think sydney's actually even seen them
out of the den yet it's a bit of a hits
or miss
when you come down here but i haven't
seen pretty since these
youngsters have been at this den but
considering that her two cubs are here
it's very likely that she is around but
she probably just keeps a very different
time
to to the others and we've only seen
corki here a few times
june obviously being more sort of around
due to the age of her cubs
but i'm sure she's fine i'm sure she's
fine she'll materialize at some point
you're looking so sad there how sad it's
looking they always look
either very naughty or very sad okay so
june is going to come around again
and joined by no doubt her two little
ones that are right
oh they're doing some squittering
let's see if you can listen i might have
to drive around
they are very very keen to get some milk
from hurt
so let's just reverse around that to our
bk
let's go and get it a nice spot i've
never live
heard pain is doing that squittering
that jamie spent so much time with the
north
clan i didn't even know it was a word um
but indeed
squishing is a word and it's that
high-pitched squealing
sound that hyenas make when they're
begging
and they're begging for milk or food
from mum ah june you've gone right
inside the den
to hide your babies from view that's
okay you're still very pretty
it's still very pretty and we can get
everybody from this view apart from
the two youngsters that have told mum
mum put your bottom
inside the hole so we can at least to
drink your milk in
the shelter of the den because it's
still hot outside
okay so looking at the spot patterns of
them you'll see the one right up at the
top
seems to be the darker of the three in
my opinion
in my opinion i think that's plonk i'm
sure some of you out there will be able
to correct me
if i'm wrong but uh we'll have to figure
out i'm sure some of you have got some
spot patterns for them already
but he's a little bit darker the spots
and all the way all the way down to
to his back in his bottom and the other
two are a little bit more pale
so i think that's him i think that's him
please correct me if i'm wrong everybody
he's coming to investigate do you agree
that they're darker bk
and looks a bit darker and he's going to
give pretty i mean
june a little bit of a a facial lick as
you do
he's got these two very nice lines
coming down his
back if you go back to the one on the
left to go and then vk
those lines there thank you michael he's
almost got a c there on his bottom
there you go back a little bit yeah he's
got a c on his bottom
he's got very dark lines coming down his
back see those
there's almost like a crocodile eating a
ball there
like a v shape with a big spot in the
middle right on his bottom he's got that
very big dark spot
on his back that should make it quite
easy to identify thanks michael for
confirming
that that is plonk who is going to be
right in june's way now he doesn't care
they all want some attention and now
this one here has got two very nice
almost vertical lines on the body of
spots you can see that
and well the other one doesn't have too
much to work with at the moment
here we go this is exactly what i
anticipated this is one of pretty
youngsters
the first one always to come and say
hello
hello cheeky you wanna come smell my
shoe again do you
i love how inquisitive they are they are
not scared at all
are you do you just like the sound of my
voice
hmm what do you smell on the tire there
you probably can't see him now huh try
to identify whether this is a male or
female but very brave
very brave aren't you
it's just so precious are you going
under the car now
okay now comes the other one a little
bit more
you know egged on by the sibling and to
come down and say hello first a little
bit of pasting on the branch
this one's a little bit bigger what are
you doing
so the the one that's by my foot is a
bit darker in color the one that you can
see in frame
it's a bit paler in color
you are very naughty
this is priceless this is priceless
there's one right over here and one
right over there
hello
so i think this first one is a female
and the one on the right is a male
you can see there's a size difference
between the two of them can't you
the one on the left but then i'm not 100
sure
i think they have been sexed before i
haven't spent enough time here to
accurately identify the male and female
between them
but i do believe one was male one was
female
child of the universe thankfully not yet
um i was
busy sitting at the den the other day
and i was enjoying i don't know i was
reading something and suddenly i felt
this warm nose touched my foot
and um i got a bit of a bit of a fright
i must admit
and then it kept coming back and it was
very interested in my shoe
um obviously i've got amazing shoes and
they must have a very
interesting smell to them but thankfully
not yet
jamie says there's also a male hyena
that sometimes will come up and do
exactly the same sort of thing you'll
have your foot here
and you'll suddenly feel this wet nose
touch you on the leg and
if the hyena wanted a bite it would it
would do some
quite a bit of damage but i think
they're more inquisitive than they are
trying to get any food from us they're
just very interested um as
dogs or hyenas aren't dogs but like dogs
they like to smell
everything so we've got all sorts of
smells to ourselves our shoes have been
all over the place our legs
and our clothes our wheel our vehicle
they've been all over the place and
well these youngsters don't get the
luxury of exploring
very far so they are very interested in
absolutely
every single smell that they can grasp
with their nose
and uh including our legs and shoes
i wonder how close they'd come to brent
leo smith's shoes though
see there's there's plonk i think
yeah but it's darker in color
he's got that almost that that c on his
bottom doesn't he
see with a hole in the c with a spot in
the middle
hello oh you're very cute where's mum
he's running where mum is he'll play
with a bit of grass while he waits
well very very tactile hyenas they love
touching
they love cuddling love spending time
with each other
it's all about touching smelling and
biting in the eye in a world and
well as we go on from this den site it
seems that
holly has found an animal that likes to
use a similar place
for sleeping
yes i'm with this
shovel like snot animal that loves to
nail when feeding not because they swag
or
how can i say this so maybe they uh
they're making fun of it it's because of
the the neck
they have they have this short neck that
doesn't allow them
to to feed for smaller things
for a long time on the ground while
feeding
while standing so what's happening now
it's we have this small family here
this is the young one you can see
it has this white like
whiskers which act as a
a tool that takes away predators
if i can put it that way because these
things they they
they look as if they are a
a tusk so a predator would be confused
whether this is a tusk or this is hey
so that's why they have these things at
this early stage
hello see the then they have uh
a lot of further than like other animals
that's why they are sensitive when it's
hot they have to wallow
in the mud so that they can keep them
their skin safe from sunburn
and they also live in in barrows they're
flexing around
around this time they will be
going or heading to to to to home or
they'll be feeding
not far away from home so the parent
you can see the task there
and it's a female because it has two
sets of
one sets of four one set of watts
yes that's a female in the male will
have two
sets of what
it's so grateful to
listen and look at these creatures while
feeding more special the youngsters
they are more relaxed you can see their
tail you know a wattage if it's not
relaxed its tail
shoot up straight
we have been palace around
and this is the best habitat you can
find these guys because they
they prefer
open woodland
oh this is what i was talking about they
are kneeling now
if they get tired they know
what is a what talk in my language
scenic
we call it ifarikiyomango
ifariki yo mango fariki means
pig and then your mango it means wild
so that's what we call these beautiful
waters in my home language that's in
their belly
what an amazing question scenic there's
a youngster
i think that one is the last one that
one because it's smaller than the other
ones
well this one is a male you can see it's
a young chapter
you can see the two heads between the
high necks there
oh it's taking a look it
moving through the thicket
it's so amazing and and nice to to look
at the waters
oh we have uh we have some migration
going on there you know on the front
ankle james
the impala migrating from a block to
another block
yes there's a male
nice one they do form
they do form this harem these males
sometimes because you know
their testosterone levels they can
slightly go up then they will act
territorial
and let me move forward and see what i
can find
we are in chitwa chito our neighboring
reserve
where we can find kuchaba
so i'm driving around maybe i'll be
lucky to get a
female leopard truck for now let's go to
steve with the hyenas
well you're just in time oh it's over
that
when hyena was busy attacking the stick
and the stick was formidable okay
well it seems like we need to move
around again we've moved once
holly i hope you managed to find a
leopard he said that's me
he asked me what my okay they're coming
back again make up your mind guys where
you want to go come on
he said to me what was my plan for this
afternoon i said what's your plan he
said i want to find a spotted cat
so i said very good you go find yourself
one good luck
well he has had some luck with him in
the past and here we
here he gave this little one sorry about
my whole body being in the shot there
but uh let's come to smell the wheel
because um
something i've seen with dogs before
when you park if you drive from
somewhere and someone's got dogs
and you park there in the driveway
especially if it's a guest house or a
backpackers or something
where the cars park the dogs always go
and urinate and defecate because
the wheels of those cars have come from
all over the country all over the place
driven through all sorts of interesting
smells
and those animals feel the need to sort
of reaffirm their scent on top of
whatever smell
it is that was left there and i've
noticed that
with dogs and hyenas aren't dogs
although they do have a very
well quite a lot of similarities with
regards to how they behave
we're going to go around again because
it seems like the other youngsters are
out again
but they are playing a game of hide and
seek with us plonk and his
cousins there you go tell me when you're
happy bk
there we go okay so
michael fleetwood sent through a tweet
saying that one of the females or one of
the one of
corki's it's not cookies one of pretty's
cubs on her right hand side has got an
e t and a smiley face and it's it's that
one
there who is getting all bitey she's
gotta
if she can turn we'll see oh no here we
go
there we go it's all fun and games now
plonkers and i decided to get involved
and this is when hyena dance can be the
most
fun when they start chasing each other
around
a little youngster's popping its head
out he wants to be part of the game
oh hello hey don't go for my shoe
i need to get a little bit of newspaper
so that if it does try to go for my shoe
i can just
bop it on the nose again it came all the
way under the car and suddenly stuck its
head right next to my foot
[Laughter]
this is the cheekiest of the two
definitely
the bravest of the two and there we're
gonna see
is that plonk yes that's plonk playing
with one of the youngsters
it's been very gentle i must admit uh
when he was
the same sort of age as the little dark
ones he was getting bullied around
like it was no one's business and he
seems to be quite gentle with the
youngsters i haven't seen any real
negative behavior
between the sort of older cubs versus
the youngsters and there you saw
uh june just gave them a proper little
look like leave my youngsters alone
although it's possible that all three of
these
sort of bigger cubs have a higher rank
than she does
now they're going to go and give her a
greeting let me maneuver the car again
so we can get some of this action
sorry folks it's a little bit of a
maneuvering this afternoon
hello june what's the matter
here we go there's a nice family photo
one two three four five six hyenas in
one
shot now i don't know what's going on
with june she doesn't look
i mean her belly looks full but she
looks very very down
she's not very happy i don't know what
happened to her last night
she doesn't seem to have any visible
wounds that i can see
certainly nina let's invite some more on
board
before i get my shoe eaten over here
good afternoon everybody welcome to juma
private game reserve in south africa
where we are with the north clan once
again who are all out
on display for us this afternoon the
biggest female there at the top is
called
june and she's got two of the cutest
little cubs
the little dark one there and there's
another one who's just poking its head
out of the hole behind her those are her
two
newest cubs of the litter and june being
the lowest ranking member
of the north not the north clan of the
juma clan
this youngster who is playing around by
her head
is indeed the one who's just walking off
to the right there that is plonk that is
the matriarch's son
and he holds a higher rank than she does
in this clan don't forget you can ask
any questions and comments you like
by just dropping them in the chat stream
below
and it's all happening all the
youngsters out this is very special
very very special indeed i'm not sure
what's going on with june she's looking
a little bit sad
today if you look at her left her right
ear there seems to be some fresh
wounds on the right ear there which she
is scratching
um it's a place where hyenas often bite
each other is in the ear
and one of the sort of characteristic
features she's had for some time is the
fact that she's had no damage done to
her ears
and now seemingly she does but she seems
to be the center of attention for all
these youngsters
with her bulging belly she seems to have
eaten
it's the little youngsters
where's you wonder if the dens are dug
by hyenas and well essentially
quite often what happens is a aardvark
has gone into a density
or into a termite mound like this
looking for termites
and then over many many years lots of
mammals
namely hyena wartog and wild dog will
actually den
inside and they all have the ability to
dig a fair amount of it out
so as to provide space inside for the uh
the pups or the cubs my bad to to breed
or to
sort of keep themselves safe from
predators
and there's a hive of activity this is
where everything goes on
all the youngsters get introduced to
hyena society
there's different ranks and standards
within the society
and you'd expect the two smallest and
youngest cubs yet to be getting beaten
around
and shown who's boss because all of the
other youngsters are higher ranking
than they are but at the moment it seems
to be nice and playful
not too much sort of animosity towards
them
the two you just saw there and shot are
actually sort of the second in charge of
the clans
uh cubs they are pretty's daughter and
son
and we haven't seen pretty in some time
but considering that her cubs are here
there's a very good chance she comes and
goes we just don't know when
well this is wonderful to be able to see
in the daytime there we go
now we're going to start seeing some
play there's a lot of rough housing that
goes on between them
lego pizza you want to know what the
favorite food is for hyenas well they
are meat eaters
and they generally are well known as as
hunters so anything between
a steinbach warthog up to impala and
even kuru wildebeest are known to be
hunted
by hyena but it seems that down here in
the sabi sands
that the hyenas probably do a lot more
scavenging than they do in other parts
of the world
where they'll regularly pick up the
carcasses and steal the carcasses
from leopards and even just pick up the
remains left over by a lion
we generally don't see the hyenas
dominating the lions down here
although it does happen from time to
time in places like the mara
the hyenas are extremely good hunters
and they take down quite large prey
as big as even buffalo but they're up in
the more
different system different behavior and
but
the behavior can be universal but it
seems to be quite
area specific i mean the juma clan is
quite small
so for them to hunt large animals it
just wouldn't happen
martin how we determine the position in
the hierarchy is just by watching
essentially you can see june here she's
standing with her head quite downcast
she's not showing any sort of
confrontational or dominance displays
her head is quite low down
her tail is tucked up below her if any
of the other adults came into the scene
we'd see how they behaved
with her and it's how they behave with
each other
that indicates exactly what is going on
in the hierarchy so
it's not us who determines it but it is
in fact the hyenas themselves
and a lot of it's got to do with
aggression and dominance but she doesn't
look
very comfortable she looks in pain
i'm not sure i can't see any visible
marks on her body
but she doesn't look very happy she got
lots of bite marks
on the back of her ears now you can
actually see it clearly now
both of her ears are very very sore so
it's possible she's had a bit of a
a um a dominant sort of display with
some of the other females within the
clan and she's feeling a little bit
sorry for herself now as she lies down
in the grass there she is see very full
belly though so it's a very good chance
that they were out
with food last night managing to fill
their belly
also at the feeding time the matriarch
being the dominant in the
hierarchy will feed first and then it
goes down in pecking order so if you
spend time with them
you figure out how to eventually
identify them all by
specific spot pattern and shape of the
ears and specific sort of marks that
stand out in the body
you can start seeing exactly who's who
and then obviously how they behave
around each other
is very important this is blanc and this
is the matriarch's son so
by all means he should be the number one
ranking hanging around here at the
moment
and let's see how he wants to suckle
hyenas do not suckle each other's cubs
these are not his
not june's cubs the two dark ones we saw
before
four are but see how they're all
dominating her
hello mina that's a great question um
hyenas have two cubs at
a time in a lifetime it's hard to say i
reckon hyenas start breeding from around
the age of three
all females become sort of breeding
ready and independent of the age of
three
and they can live up to the age of
between probably 12 and maybe 20
in the wild all depending on where they
stand in the hierarchy
so every two years or so two and a half
years they'll have cubs
so you can do the math there probably
hard to say hard to stay off the top of
my head but five six litres perhaps
maybe seven
at the most i wouldn't say any more than
that uh but obviously there are
exceptions to the rule but those two
there are her first
and you can see that there's no nothing
holding them back as there's lots of
biting
and dominance and june is coming to do
some discipline there
although she has no right to discipline
the offspring
of hers her betters
i kind of think of it as a royal family
you can imagine
someone trying to discipline the queen's
son the prince
it wouldn't happen would it not without
your head being decapitated from your
body
so there we go she's giving a very nice
cleaning as good
mothers do after the youngsters have
been suckling for a little bit of time
but everybody
we hope you've enjoyed this short time
with us here at the active duma den
if you'd like to continue watching we
will be still live on youtube for
another hour and 40 minutes
so please feel free to come and join us
then until next time have a beautiful
beautiful evening and we'll see you
again later goodbye
so
hello everybody so june's not looking
very happy is she
you're not looking very happy the little
youngsters are looking happy
but she is not she's got a bit of a limp
to her back left leg
she's not far at all from the den we
first saw her when she came out of the
muddy walla and i thought maybe it was
to do the fact
that she was sinking into the wallow a
little bit but her head is hanging low
her back left
is uh doesn't look very injured that
doesn't seem to be any injury that i can
see on her back left leg
it's very wet from her being in the mud
but she's definitely favoring herself
her ears look like something's gone on
in the night
but we do not know we were not here what
goes on
in the night with hyenas very hard to
say
must be a very hard life being a hyena
always trying to figure out where you
stand in the system
having to compete with the ever presence
of lions
there's always leopards around
other clans as well not only your own
constantly busy
there we go that looks more comfortable
now she's pulled her back legs out there
flying very flat good ears though big
cat men are looking great are they
got bite marks all over on the inside
and the outside it definitely looks like
bites
so i think she got a bit of a a telling
off
at some point maybe she
overstepped the mark her full belly may
be testaments to the fact that she ate
more than she was supposed to at a
at a kill corki most likely telling her
who was boss
and now she's looking quite dejected and
sad
that's okay it just looks healthy
see naina's with incredible injuries
coming back are you still here you
little naughty
keeps popping up from under the car
[Laughter]
got a very nice line on the left side of
the body that kind of angles
and the side as well it's got that two
sort of almost parallel lines on the one
side
almost like ribbon sort of markings on
the body
trying to identify i think this is a
male this one not 100
sure well talking about hard
life an animal out here that seemingly
doesn't have too much of a hard time
for most of the time anyway because they
are so big and ferocious sydney is
still with the possibly sleeping kahuma
pride
we are still with the umkuhumas here
they are very much relaxed at the moment
and please don't get surprised i am not
my i am not alone at the sighting i do
have
the other vehicles who are enjoying the
same sighting as
us this afternoon and these lions are
still very much pretty relaxed
two of them already defecated so they
just
walked away a little bit few meters
three meters and then they defecated so
we had to change the position because
this cut was not smelling nice their
droppings were smelling very bad there
so i can see that now they are starting
to become active and i saw
the manganese male is fully recovered
now i can see there is no sign of mage
at all if you look at him all the hairs
are back
and he's just lying down here look at
that that is the mangane male
so if you look at the side of the bodies
and the
main is also showing off there a little
bit and
the head is also fully covered so they
don't have any bare
patch on their body at the moment unless
it's on the other side because i only
saw
one side when he was coming to this at
bat i could also manage to see that
the tassel by the tail is normal
so you can see that they are all still
lying down very close to each other
the tail is very much important for the
lions you must check
all these cats the tail is important for
balance
especially the cast that climbs trees
such as the leopard
but to the lions tails can also serve as
a non-verbal communicator
because this kind of animals can be able
to showcase
their internal mode just from the tail
let me give you an example
at home if you've got a domestic dog and
you
have visitors who brought another
domestic dog
when the visitor comes to the
territorial holder
when the territorial holder is growling
you will see the visitor putting the
tail in between the hind legs which is a
sign
of submission so the tale itself
a very important purpose when it comes
to the non-verbal
communication so when the females has
got cups
they do communicate from the tail as
well
so you can see those two there has got
very nice black tips behind the ears
so this is so amazing look at that look
at those black
pages there and one of them on the right
i can see he has got a
a mite there it doesn't look like a tick
from here where i
am so the mice they are those who can
transmit diseases such as the image as
we saw from these
manganese it is transmitted by the
scurvies
so those are the ticks the mics
which can be giving these kind of
animals problems when it comes to the
diseases
such as mange and then they experience
hair loss
and each itching too much
so imagine if the animal is experiencing
mange
by this time of the year when there is
quite a lot of flies
so it means when they are scratching
against the trees and the ground
they get a lot of blood coming out and
which will then attract
these kind of flies to come there so i'm
very sure that can be a very difficult
experience
so now and while we are waiting for the
lions to
show us what they're thinking about to
do this
afternoon let's go back to the hyenas
welcome back everyone what you're seeing
now is june trying to make right what
happened
she was sitting where you last saw her
all cuddled up and looking very
uncomfortable
and her one little youngster came
charging towards the car
and then something happened she got a
fright and turned around to run
backwards
and then that other individual there
that's got its head in the hole came
running up behind and completely took
out the little dark individual
and that caused june to jump up after
obviously it squealed and made a whole
lot of noise
and it caused june to discipline this
one very briefly
and then to run off to the den to see if
everything's okay with her little baby
so francis from israel says that there
was fights between hyenas and
wild dogs last night around a coroll
well i'm not sure if the juma clan goes
that far
and if it was wild dog i think there
would be a lot of bites on her bottom
um that's where hyena and wild dog when
they fight they get a lot of injuries on
their bums especially if they get
outnumbered
but the bites on it is seem to be uh
bites from hyenas but i don't know
i didn't see it happen myself but it's
not serious injuries
it doesn't seem to be any ripping just a
discipline really
but she doesn't look comfortable at all
everybody have a look at how gingerly
she's moving
the whole right side of her body oh well
that was awkward
okay so everybody it just so happens
that uh fc
recorded the tumble so as soon as we are
ready nina's going to
show it for you and i'll send you across
to a little bit of a recap
let's go back up there bk so everybody
did you see that little replay
thanks for the technology we have we're
able to capture that stuff
i do apologize my game drive radio is
not working so i've got a handheld
but with that technology we're able to
to replay some things
quite quickly for you because it just
happened before you came
to us so now you're able to see that the
big one it wasn't really trying to hurt
the little one it just happened
uh one of those things you know when you
get frightened and you turn around and
run the other direction
you can see he's saying i'm sorry dude
you are the play thing today there's
plonk plonk wants some milk
this is where jude should step in and
say no that's not for you
i don't care who your mom is
but she's not disciplining him she's oh
she's having a go
not a proper thing just a bit of body
language
his ears are flat he's acknowledging
that he shouldn't be doing that but
she isn't really disciplining him if she
did
i think she would have some trouble with
his mother
you know what it's like everybody you
can't discipline someone else's child
i think we should in most cases but it's
not
really allowed around the world anymore
very very cool to be able to spend this
time at the density
to see all the little things happening
june's youngsters looked like they
wanted to suckle again until
um plonker got involved
i'm sure they will come back shortly but
you see
june doesn't look very happy her head is
down she's looking up every now and
again almost in anticipation for
someone else to be materializing back
normally they just look very lazy and
lie down
suckle but she's quite vigilant and
quite alert maybe it's because she's
been thrown in
with babysitting duty
tommy i have no idea about what happens
in ethiopia but
i have no doubt there's still some very
bad practices going on
around the world with regards to animals
and animal cruelty and
people that tease or feed hyenas are not
ideal you do not want these animals
learning
or losing fear of man excuse me
excuse me you do not want these
animals losing fear of man because if
they decide to start coming into camps
and start trying to get food
well there's nothing going to stop them
really and the bite force of aina would
just
cause some serious damage to an
individual's leg
neck body arm whatever they decide to
grab
so feeding wild animals and for the most
part i'm highly highly against that
because they learn a manner of getting
food that is not natural to them
and then they start becoming what we now
call problem animals but
the problem is the people who start the
practice in the first place
don't feed wild animals everybody they
all surviving archer
how they survive is the way that if the
evolution moves forward
and those that don't manage to survive
don't breed
kev there potentially could be
branagines there's nothing stopping them
coming in
um but with the high abundance of other
predators the braanagenas are
essentially excluded
um there's been a competition going for
years in the kruger park for someone to
get a photograph
of ibrahim i've most certainly seen
tracks
but i've never actually seen a branham
in the kruger
they generally do shy away from areas of
high spotted hyena density
generally occurring in sort of more arid
areas where they've got much larger
ranges
we find them on our east west coast in
namibia and find them in botswana
areas where they can range much further
away than
spots lagina's can and where there's
lions and obviously leopards as well
high density of predators the prana unit
really doesn't do very well
in that regard so i hope that answers
your question
i would love to show you one they are
very very cool but i actually feel like
they have been seen
recently but i know there was a
competition going for years
in the kruger about getting one on
camera but it wasn't me
it wasn't me okay well looks like june
wants us to go around
to the other side once again which we
will gladly do
all the little bundles of joy over there
that's maybe why she's looking so
dejected she's the only one here to look
after all these naughty things
okay we're going to stop over here again
bk because we've got a little cuteness
over there on the hole have you got him
there we go a little ball
of cuteness right there
this is so cute
there's lots of activity going on
there's not as much play as i thought
they would be
not as much biting and chewing and
pulling
oh very good so the viewers have seen
the branagino drive
when was that exactly not since i've
been here i'm not
i don't think if it was it's not
something that i heard about
but was it here or was it in the
masayamara
the brahma you know very interesting
very very interesting
someone can hopefully give me some
information about where and when
that was seen hello naughty come up
behind me again
2009 the brannagino was seen on drive so
that must have been
here in the sabi sands very very good no
doubt a very rare occurrence
very rare occurrence indeed
i've seen them a handful of times in
southern botswana in a reserve called
mashatu
and i have definitely seen their tracks
in the northern kruger
the back foot versus the front foot
being extremely small
in comparison to that of a spotlight in
a spotter in the tracks
the back foot is smaller but nowhere
near as small as that
of the brahma in and often in the track
as well in the front foot
of the braana hina you can actually see
some fur
because they've got quite a lot of
shaggy fur on their feet
okay well while we pay attention to
these very naughty hyenas that are very
interested in my shoe
ollie is probably off the vehicle trying
to show you a beautiful beautiful flower
look what we i've found i found a purple
top
plant which is also known as syncholos
demon
bracteosus it's very common here and
in zimbabwe in zimbabwe in china they
call it
this is a very good looking tree and it
yeah it smells very nice
it smells like lavender
i'm not sure whether the flowers are
smelly but the leaves
are smelly let me smell it
they are smitty jesus i'm sorry about
that
uncle james do you need some yes please
smells very great
i think i have to have to harvest a few
and put it in the vehicle
yeah let me go at the back here
nice looking flower pebble top
in zimbabwe they call it that
so let me make it 10 sorry
and look what i have for you
you know what what this is
it's it's very long it starts from here
to here it's about the size of my hand
this is called
ecasia
it was also called it was once called a
chambok
pot but the name changed from chamber
pot
to kasia i don't know why it changed or
maybe because the shambok
name it doesn't sound right and what it
does is in my culture
are ready for that
it helps with that's too graphic i don't
think i'll tell that
but it helps with the manhood like a uh
like a a sausage tree
fruit
just imagine
so i'm a ninja now it's my sword so why
they
they used to call it the shambo pot is
because uh
uh it it it looks more like a chambock
you know chambok used to whip whip with
with whip
that's why it's called a schambach
port and these things we
we used to play with them but we didn't
know that they can help with
hut but when we're still voice we used
to like make swords out of them and wear
our mask there
you know this is a mask this cheap mask
you can find in a in a shop
and you cover the face then like paper
or plastic
plastic ones then you will like chew
yeah
let me put it right here
yes i'm a ninja now
so i'm at uh kuchabus territory
i haven't seen any fresh tracks yet
hopefully i'll find them and it's not
going to
be an easy task because you can see the
sun is
already going down it's cloudy
the lighting is compromised
so while i'm busy looking at
cuchaba let's go to the hyenas
nothing molly don't injure yourself now
with your newly acquired
shambok i think i need one of them to
keep these youngsters in line
coming too close sometimes well they are
now attacking everything in sight
around the dan side nothing is safe
around dahina den
nothing at all they have made their
first kill over there
a couple of sticks had no chance
absolutely no chance and be care this
little youngster is coming
very very close one of the new ones he
was inside the den before
or she i can't really tell and there was
some digging going on
there was some fresh earth being pushed
out obviously from the rain
he's like mum why are you so far away
why are you all the way over there
good's like eight meters from the hole
mum i've got to get past this weird
looking thing
there we go i'm going to brave it oh i
don't know
and there's that like flat distance you
know like can it make it
there's like something needs to get past
here and once it's passed it'll get to
mum and everything will be fine
it's not quite sure she's just too far
away from the dead
they know that safety is in the den they
know that they need to be able to run
back there in case of danger looking
very longingly at mum going mum
come on are you going to be braver this
time
i'm going to be braver come on my
cousin's over there surely i can make it
surely i can make it
a little bit more little one okay say
hello to mum
go say hello come on oopsie
plonk just chased her that's not very
nice
trying to venture out of the den
seemingly started to change the spots
already seems like a lot of the dark fur
around the head area is starting to
change
might be due to just a lot of licking
janet male hina's mainly dispersed some
of them
can stay in the clad like plonk for
example where
he'll inherit his mom's rank in the clan
he might even be able to take it over
from her at some stage
but that means it might limit any mating
opportunities
within a clad males that are normally
natal to the clan don't generally get
too many mating opportunities
females preferring males that have come
in from another clan
so quite often what happens at the age
of three or so males within a clan will
move away
to go and form or to become part of
another clan and also to go and improve
their opportunities of mating
but it's not unheard of of them to stay
but then
they generally still don't have any rank
if they are quite low ranking
or their mothers are ranked low ranking
and they might not do any mating at all
so
choice is really theirs
that stick is really wishing it wasn't
there i really wish i didn't grow here
it's thinking
important stages of the iron is
strengthening their teeth
very important stage their teeth that
are probably constantly growing in their
mouth
like everyone who does have a dog back
home they love to chew
to chew things to to sharpen their teeth
get the jaw muscles working
no chew toys around here only sticks
nothing wrong with the stick though it's
organic
plenty of them around
nancy that's a really good question i'm
not sure i mean initially
a mum has to go in to breed so she digs
the initial hole
and then the youngsters once they're
able to sort of see a little bit are
probably able to dig themselves in a
little bit deeper
but what really goes on inside the den
is very hard to know because to be able
to view these things naturally
in the wild without influencing them is
almost impossible
without maybe setting up some form of
camera but we were just talking about
dan sites and while we're talking about
chew toys imagine setting up some sort
of
form of gopro inside a hyena den i don't
think it would last very long
it'll probably get eaten in a very short
space of time
i did watch a wild dog documentary that
wild earth was involved in
on juma oh there we go there's going to
be some
some false mating there a bit of a
dominance thing
between siblings
and the wild dogs then um had what
seemed to be a gopro or something inside
and is able to show the mum
and all her offspring in the early
stages
but um it didn't show them at an a at an
older stage so it probably got to a
point where the youngsters were so
inquisitive
they ended up eating it and it's
probably one of those things that you'll
have to sacrifice
if you want to keep any form of camera
equipment
well you need to know if you put it
inside of a dance site it's going to get
eaten
but i haven't found anything that
details too much about what goes on
inside there's lots of theories and
ideas
people talk about infanticide or sorry
siblicide that happens between
offspring in the den where the bigger of
the two will often kill the other
it's not something i've ever seen
something that's spoken about but what
goes on inside the dent
really really is another matter
obviously it could be quite intrusive
to get inside there to send some form of
of ronald the rover inside no doubt
if it did get past the line of defense
would definitely get eaten
but the channels and tunnels inside are
probably quite elaborate
the plonk cousin just came charging past
they have got themselves a stick which
they are now going to compete over
brian i don't have a number for you to
be honest on how often they change
but i think within the last few months
they've changed probably three times
but what causes them to change a lot of
it's got to do with parasites
uh ticks fleas and the like a lot of
it's also got to do with the presence of
predators maybe visiting the site
caused them to maybe up and leave we had
the juma den sort of in
a bit further north east where we are
now and that was there for a few months
and then they vanished we don't know
where they got where they went to and
they were south of the boundary we
believe
and then they disappeared from there and
then we found them here again so we
really don't know
i think seasonality might play a part
life cycles of the parasites the insects
that feed on them
apart and also the presence of other
predators
for example the density in the mara get
flooded and inundated with water which
will force them
to leave and to choose a new one um if
we get a
a hole here in the ground for example
one of these large termite mounds they
could get inundated with water as well
depending on the amount of rain that
falls and how it falls
a lot of rain fell last night but it
doesn't seem to have affected these guys
too much
but that'll all play a part seasonality
rain
other predators parasite loads i don't
think there's any sort of hard and fast
rule the hyena says okay cool it's been
two weeks let's go
it doesn't quite work like that
jude you are looking very very sad with
life
so some of the tweets coming through
mention that there's a video
on hukumuri wild dogs and hyenas
fighting
and potentially on elephant planes
which is very very interesting indeed
very interesting indeed i haven't
managed to
to watch it yet because i'm in quite a
low
signal area so i can't see that video
yet those of you who've posted
thanks for sharing and um
what a hive of activity we are having
here today
this is probably the most active i've
ever experienced the hyena den
and i think the cloud cover pulling in
has got a lot to do with that
it'll be nice to see some of the other
adults coming back
let me see how jun interacts with him
when they do
there's just a plethora of smells archer
for these individuals they just can't
stop sniffing
obviously having an adults on site makes
it possible for them
without the adult they are always
hiding in the side okay well i'm going
to maybe try reposition it seems like
all the action is happening on that side
and while we do so
let's go to see if sydney's flat cats
could get any flatter
not much has been happening here where
the unkumas are resting this afternoon
all we have been hearing is the
elephants pushing down trees and
trumpeting
far away from where we are so the
woman's are still very much relaxed and
only three of them defecated so far
as a result of digesting
a lot of maybe meat or food for the
whole day
so now it's time for them to offload so
that when they start
entertaining the night or the nocturnal
life
they can be very light and run long
distances
remember the energy is needed and they
must have to be light so that
if need be they can chase something
they are going to come across
so this is a strategy it is a strategy
for the lions in order to manage
the energy this has got something to do
with the management of
energy so that they conserve energy
during the day time
in order to use at night
firefly that is quite a very lovely
question
if the avocado one of the famous
and beautiful coalitions in the area if
they decide to go somewhere else
remember
correlations are very much uh nomadic
they just move around
trying to have an opportunity all the
time so
here if the avocado correlation moves
the
females here we are seeing possibilities
of the other males to come
in and deal with them are very much high
yes females as well they do
entertain going out and look for the
males
especially if these males are strong and
they are showing good genes
and loud roars i have seen this
happening let me share with you
something that i have shared there's
something that i have seen
many years ago when i was still a head
guide by the moroccan national park
in south africa about 180 kilometers
away from johannesburg
one day i was on a guided walk and there
was
an introduction of these new males
because we were trying to avoid
inbreeding
so these new moles when they arrived in
the park
some of them were very good and big with
the black mane
these nice black good-looking males the
east lion started
trespassing and roaring and marking on
top of the other territory
and the territorial holder was so old
and
he was roaring coming we were hearing
him
and then we had a sighting of these
one male in charge of three females and
the new
rival came roaring and one of the males
voluntarily
one of the females voluntarily went and
look
who is roaring went and joined that one
and
suddenly they went and this old male
decided to run away when that one was
roaring coming
he could hear that here there is a
danger coming
this one is too big and it's gonna
destroy me the territorial holder ran
away
and the new male came in the females
entertained him
and welcomed him
so you can see that now they are still
i have heard uh something about the
stixx pride
but they're aware about i am not too
sure but i hear that there is
a stix pride in the area which is one of
the
beautiful prize as well but the chances
of seeing the sticks prize
are very much low at the moment so
just same applies to the telematics i
have
last seen them long time ago
so at least the unkurumas are becoming
uh
much more regular because these are the
ones
i'm seeing a lot of times together with
the avocados
what's up
uh james i didn't copy your question
very well but i just heard you want to
know something about me
and the vehicle
james that is a very important question
uh when i am in the vehicle all i've got
to do
every time is to remain seated if i
stand here now i am going to break the
shape of the vehicle
these lines you are seeing here in front
of me when
seeing me in the vehicle as well as
senzo
they see us as one object
when we stand is when we are going to
break the shape
and they will start to notice and
realize
there is a movement so that is why it is
important that
we remain seated and we move very slowly
so you can see that the presence of the
vehicle
is not wearing these lions they are very
much relaxed at the moment
steve the lions
how they talk we do understand some of
the things but some we don't
why because of the following they can
make
loud rolls and they can growl those are
the kind of communication we can
understand that
when he's growling like when he's doing
that
when i'm coming close he's saying no
that is enough
keep a distance i don't want you to come
closer anymore
so then we can read that but also
if you listen to them when they're
roaring we understand that
when roaring they are trying to
advertise themselves
in a territory has got nothing to do
with our presence
when we are with them
so apart from growling again when
they're just showing off
their front teeth as we are coming
closer when just showing off the front
teeth and close the mouth again
we can read that he's talking to me i
must have to now stop
and observe
so but at the moment they're all
sleeping so they're not showing any sign
so now while we are waiting for the
lions to wake up as now i can see that
the sun
is going to set maybe in a very short
while
let's go back to the hyenas i'm not
going anywhere
i will be here waiting to see what is
going to happen
thanks so this hopefully your pride gets
up
soon and shows you something because
we're having all the fun here
all of the five littlest ones are out
the two little cuties are out there
they're starting to sort of change you
see around the neck and head area
those sort of spots that started to
change so what are they about two months
then
i thought maybe only a month in a bit
but it's seemingly a bit older than i
was aware
but we didn't see them from the
beginning but they've changed so much in
the last few
in the last week already and see how all
the hair's starting to
disappear around the neck that's where
the first
spots started to come through on the
back of the head
and they are getting quite brave this
one just here on the right
and gates up so they start changing
colors about between two months
and so the youngsters that you see now
start to change the spots you can start
seeing them around the head
and neck area but it's only after four
months four and a half months that they
start looking like these are the three
little hooligans over here
on the right um remember plonk he was
just behind by half a month and his
whole
bottom part of his body was still quite
dark although the top of his body had
changed
and within well last time we saw him
should i say when they're at the other
den
that's what he looked like and then out
of nowhere three weeks or so a month
later
he looks just like a little adult
did you see that little one face planted
as you ran down the hill he's trying to
say hello to plonk he face planted
himself
it is a heart of activity this after
dude
i hope you're all getting all of your
screenshots in we are super blessed that
we're able to
have all these little visitors and to
watch this intimate behavior between
them all
and obviously as soon as you come back
to us they will decide they want to go
back to the other side now
because it's always better on the other
side isn't it
we're doing like a half circle around
this mound and back again
and june is just on the other side
they're lying down
but they're too inquisitive to leave us
alone for long
they'll be back in the moment i'm sure
that raisin bush is getting a hammering
once again
probably that's a really good question i
mean i
i think it's it's okay i really don't
have a a number for you or a figure for
you
i know a lot of the viewers watching
have probably got a much better idea of
the scenario
and i've only been working here for just
over a year
but um they're not no new ones with us i
mean these are the only hyena cubs that
we know of
over the last five to six months but
then they didn't den on juma so it's
hard to say i know
that there was d1 and d2 that were born
in the year before
that no one knows anything about them
where they're gone um
but i'm sure some of you out there have
got your statistics for us
and know exactly how many of these
hyenas are surviving
i honestly don't know it's it's well
well beyond what i know at the moment
but i think the survival rate is is
better than that
of lions due to the fact that they've
got
the dan site hyenas only have two
youngsters lions can have anywhere up to
four or five at times
it really depends on the individual but
lions don't have as
much success we haven't seen the
umkuhumas doing very well in the last
year
and with the last sets of cubs perishing
to white muscle disease and then that
one individual
just not making it through at the end
and amber eyes we believe has probably
had at least two litters already since
i've been here
she's pregnant again but nothing so very
hard to say
what we do know is we've got five
individuals here that are looking good
these two youngsters of of uh june are
looking
very very huge bk much better than my
face i'm sure
seeing as you've got cuteness overload
there let's keep the camera framed on
them shall we
so they're looking very very good it's
still early days to say whether these
two will survive
but i really don't have a figure for you
with regards to survival rate
um obviously having two hedges the bets
against
one not making it um a plonk being only
one
we don't know if he had a sibling and
then the other two
for pretty not doing very very well
they're close to six months now
uh so in the next two to three months
they'll probably be venturing away from
the den
looking for food for themselves but
we're talking about the absence or
presence of pretty have we seen her
haven't we
this is one of the youngsters here uh
they're still looking in good condition
which means she's clearly been around
to feed them because hyenas don't
accumulate it will not provide milk
for their sister's offspring not at all
so for them to be looking in as good a
condition as plank
means that pretty must be visiting the
den
and providing them with food
this little one can't get enough of the
camera
i wonder if it realizes how cute it is
janet that's a really good question
about rank changing with a new clan
um well what would cause a clan to
change and what would cause them to do
that
and maybe a mid sort of ranking female
might move often
she might find herself or take with her
some males
and most certainly if if a female or two
females moved off
then one of them would most likely
through a dominance display
that looks painful the dominance display
will then establish who will be the
matriarch
um so most certainly a rank would
probably change but
within a clan uh it can only change
through
dominance and it's not it's not uncommon
for it to happen but
we don't really see it i haven't
honestly spent enough time sorry that
they're going behind the car everybody
but we are we are free to their
movements here i haven't really spent
enough time
to be able to give you that sort of
information but i mean we we know quite
well that waffles was a low-ranking
female and she just decided to take over
one day
she was her mum wasn't oh let me put my
legs back in because you want to come
and say hello again don't you
it's you again i'm gonna call you
naughty
let's not keep that we'll just it'll get
a name soon
we'll get her name very soon but um
waffles went and just took over
and she dominated completely going from
quite low ranking
to to becoming the leader of the clan up
there for for whatever time it was that
she was in charge
um but if they do form a new clan
there's a very good chance
obviously that those that go off will
then start from the top again
probably one of the reasons for starting
a new clan if that happens i don't know
how often it happens
i mean i honestly think that the world
of the hyena is very understudied
in fact i mean in the mara we've got
enormous clans they are enormous
numbering 70 to 100 individuals
here five adult females with males
coming in and out we don't even know
that's nowhere near on the same level in
the gorogora crater
also enormous clans of hyena there so
how do you keep a rank with a hundred
animals in your clan how is that
possible the world of the hyena amazes
me
there they are again the little rascals
the structure the dynamics the behavior
and they're gonna force me to move again
they're gonna force us to move again
because no yeah they come
like don't move we're coming sorry about
the aerial
we're having a great time with the jew
mclaren this afternoon
and those two are siblings plonk is the
one playing off in the background
and these two are doing their own
dominance display right now
with lots of biting tail pulling
and they'll always be in every family
a bully or more dominant than in the
other
so i'm quite chuffed now spending time i
can identify these two quite easily
some nice spot patterns coming through
and uh so you start seeing this sort of
behavior this one here
keeps coming up right underneath my car
you suddenly look around and there's his
head looking at my leg
here's the one with the parallel lines
on the body
another one it's got a apparently a
smiley face and an
e t e t then one on the left there
there's an e t and a smiley face the one
on the right has got those pretty much
parallel lines
and then plonk interestingly enough i've
noticed now has got
two very nice sort of pale spots
on his his hips at the back and when you
see it in a moment
you'll notice you'll see what i mean
it's
definitely the sibling at the on the
right much bigger
than the other one most likely female
and
showing him whose boss the plonk
has got these two very nice sort of
white sort of pale patches
where the bones of his hips two blonde
patches there mac he's gonna come
through now watch him come
there he comes straight across look at
the patches on his hips
his back hips there and you see there's
a one patch quite easy to see isn't it
he's also got the very dark sort of
coloration but he's
trying to find out why they aren't
playing with him
keep moving away from him you know what
it's like in any royal family
uh you don't ever play with the prince
because lo and behold you go and injure
him
he goes and sulks hormones to mum and
then mum comes along and disciplines
everybody with beheadings
so they're not playing with plonk at all
he's uh as soon as he materializes on
the scene they both stop playing and
walk away
but here he comes look at those two
blonde patches on his
on his back hips very easy to see isn't
it
there we go hello plonk come and say
hello to everybody and show us
your wonderful patches on your bottom
okay well very good it seems like
siddhis has turned his camera from his
lazy lions and he is
taking a moment to watch the sunset
what a beautiful sunset you can see that
the sun is burning in the middle of
those clouds there
look at that colors there a nice
reflection of the sun
there so the sun is going to lead us to
the beginning
of the nocturnal life soon as the sun
goes down
the hyenas are going to start calling
the lions are going to start roaring
and the leopards are going to start
sewing it's going to be
lovely here in the wilderness
look at that this is gorgeous
i always tell people the sunset never
gets old and thank you very very much
senzu for such a beautiful shot
so you can see that the chances of us to
get some more rains tonight they are
very much high
look at those dark clouds there
so that is where the thunderstorm was
taking place earlier when we started we
could hear
it is raining somewhere not far look at
that
so the sun can be very hot i come from
the equatorial region
in vendor
and some of us in the different parts of
vendor
we are so very much dark because of the
sun
but the very same sun which is bearing
us too much
to get those kind of colors does also
provide us with vitamin d
giraffe girl i didn't get your question
nicely if you can repeat that i haven't
heard from you for quite a long time
giraffe girl unfortunately we haven't
heard
any sowing for quite a long time and the
one who is dominating the most when it
comes to that here in this area
it is the la the leopard called tingana
here where these lions are it is in
tingana's territory
and when tingana is in here is inside
the unkumas territory so in the bush
animals are sharing
although they compete and even kill each
other
as a result of different competitions
that
they are surviving it's about survival
of the free test
so these predators are surviving by
avoiding each other every day
so when the lions are starting to do
this now when they're starting to groom
uh each other and groom themselves it
means
now is going to be the time so the wind
now is getting cooler
i can feel it so the possibilities of
this pride
to stand and start moving they are very
much high
so they are going to start yearning very
shortly here
so the lions they are they form part of
what is called
persuade predation pursuit predation has
got something to do
with the pride hunting together
there is a dependency when they are
going for a hand and each one of them
has got its own role
which is different from the other and
they've got different positions
when they are cornering an animal they
play different positions
all the time and sometimes if they mix
the positions
the chances of them to catch a prey they
becomes very much slim
because they are not used to the
different positions
here by this pride we have got those
that go
and corner the animals and those that
chase
and the ones that caught that catch they
pray as well
so while i am still waiting you can hear
that i've been saying this for quite a
long time
waiting and waiting about what is going
to happen
we are going to call it and hear what
tully is
having at the moment
i'm still not luck yet i came back to
our territory
which is juma from chitwa
then we are with the guide which is
called aubry
then he said he had the baboons alamo
calling
on the east side of the reserve so we're
on our way to
to check there but he said didn't see
any tracks
of a leopard so maybe you'll feel like
you will see
tracks around there
and while we were off air we we saw this
beautiful bread which is a common cuckoo
but it was brown to
to rufus color and we thought it was a
female yeah it's a female rufus
yeah it was my first time seeing the
color it's a european cuckoo
and you know the cuckoo ceramics sit
still they fly
every time
and the surfaces are difficult now it
would be hard to to spot the tracks
because you know
if it rained last night and then we have
the sun light the substrate
gets compacted and then you know the
leopards and
cats they are these fragile walkers so
it's not easy to sport
the the tracks so
on the ground so these are the places
where we have to check for
for the tracks so i'll be going out for
a few seconds and
and check whether we'll find tracks
there
nothing only see impalas impalas
impala nothing
impalas and a wartock nothing
yes maybe we'll be lucky before
the end of the show
because sometimes we get lucky to that
point that these lepers they show
themselves to us
after a long search
ankle stiff is lucky with the hyenas
hortman
uh sydney fumlani mikosi is lucky with
their lines
not like yet
means a big guy that's why i called
sidney hrotman because that's a
touch of africans with he's a big guy
so sometimes you have to rely
on luck because you can see the
place is thick very thick
and the smell they can tell you the
smell of the wild
she wants to know what's that red thing
there oh this thing there it's a
the jack it's a high lift jack it's
called a high lift jack raven
this is what we have to have all the
time
because you know we're in the wild and
if we get stuck or in the mud
then we have to check the car using that
thing
i think we have to paint it green or
camouflaged
or the same color as this vehicle
listen to that we have this guy here
listen to that
sometimes they do this and then they
will dance they'll open their wings and
dance
this is called a red-billed
haunt bell you can see the the peak of
the peel is sharp
and then the yellow pill hold people
have this blunt
and i don't know whether the fuel made
because this one that's responding
on the right there but they can't see it
because of this tree
and we find a lot
of these guys here
let me keep quiet and listen to to his
call
because it seems like it needs to be
given time to
to to talk
how it's grooming there so it's easily
confused with the yellow peeled horn
pill
the only thing you have to check is the
peak
and then we have the horn peel which is
this one
the red bill hornbill yellowfield
the southern ground hornbill and this
one called the tocus
nysutis which is a grey hornbill
i caught in the
the horn pillar is wearing a nice suit
because of its scientific name
they might have a nest somewhere here
so let's move forward james and see
whether
we'll be lucky with the tracks
nice one nice call right
i have some technical issues with my
with my combs here
i can hear fc but wow
oh how scenic how big is a hornpill
territory
uh it depends which hornpill because we
have the
southern crown horn pill yellow peeled
horn pill red pill hunt pill
and a gray haunter
so we have this horn pill in the camp
let me talk about those ones we have the
yellow peel horn pill in the camp
and there are two of them so their
territory is
around the camp they they don't want any
hunt field around there
because some hot people might come but
they will normally chase them away
so i think it can be
determined by the food source that they
get because if
if you check
a territory gets more bigger when
there's
less food around and then if there's
enough food in territory
it will stay smaller
that's what but the the the actual size
of their territory
i don't know
okay i've had that i can go to steve
now with an update and see what he has
for us
thank you paulie well i hope you do
manage to find a leopard we are now
searching for a lep at the den site
something happened like a bellwen
they all went to bed they didn't come
out again so we decided well let's go
and see
if we can challenge paulie to see who
can find
the first spotted cat for the afternoon
ollie are you ready
three two one go leopard challenge is on
now we're going to see who will be the
first one to find a leopard after the
reigns
leopards do come back or they do stop
moving around to demarcate and
rescent mark their territory so it's a
great time now that's getting cool like
this for a leopard to be moving around
and
as paulie was talking about with the
hornbills they don't demarcate
territories the way leopards do they
don't scent mark they do this funny
thing with their wings don't ask me to
do that again
but just i was going to touch on the
hornbills a little bit because
well the hornbills in camp can be quite
frustrating because i've got a glass
window and a glass sliding door and
james will probably agree as well
the hornbills they love to come just at
the time when you're having an app
and they come and they attack the window
with their beak because they see a
hornbill in the mirror
the reflection they attack it it is and
they've got a very powerful beak and it
says this knocking sound
and sometimes they fly right into it to
try and
shout or fight whoever it is and sadly
at the end of last year i actually
found a hornbill that i think attacked
my car my mirror on my car the little
side mirror and ended up breaking its
neck
very sad car one hornbill zero in that
case
but um they do do it they're very well
known for breaking mirrors
grand hornbills will attack another
hornbill quite
violently they either accept it in as a
a new member of their family or they
attack it
and kill it so any sort of windows
low-lying reflective windows anywhere
in the african bush that the large grand
hornbills come near
they will break they will break you've
got no chance
they're able to break towards the shells
and no chance of you not having a window
broken
so hornbills the red and the yellow the
red we've got them outside my room at
the moment and
well as much as i love them they're
quite annoying at the moment
they've replaced the woodland kingfisher
for their loud noise
because they make a lot of noise outside
my room as they compete for food
one thing is they do catch lots of the
insects that get attracted by
sort of the lights around our buildings
and they kind of hang out sort of
around the building during the daytime
in the hornbills cup and clean them all
up which is great
they sit on a chair outside my room and
defecate all over my porch
all over my yoga mat should probably
stop leaving it on the ground
i've started rolling it up and putting
it away now
okay well this is pangolin track i
wonder where clawley is
i wonder where he's searching for
leopard this is a great road
for leopards and the one just above us
is called ingui alley
ingue meaning leopard alley oh great one
as well this one takes us straight to
chelepan
and the heart of drummond the morty
drainage where we often find
lots of leopards moving up and down so i
managed to get a little bit of signal
there a moment ago and i watched that
video posted by nkoro
and it definitely was sort of in the the
south
west because when we found shidulu
yesterday morning all the vehicles we
saw on the road were talking about how
wild dogs had treeed a leopard
they weren't telling us who it was um
but wow
watching there we go there's some
leopard food in the road
so watching those at least two hyenas
being assaulted
by and probably what was it looked like
at least eight dogs
definitely were having a hard time the
hyenas weren't backing down
but pearl hukumuri was sitting in the
tree looking very sad for himself
i need to see that that man turning and
looking at the victim for a change with
the scrub hair right here
regarded by the sand as a very
intelligent animal
he is very wily and very sort of
capable of determining and figuring out
things and
quite a term of endearment towards them
because they're very very
very smart in the animal kingdom
according to the sand
their ability to escape predators being
one of them
he sits his time of day he knows he's
been spotted so he's standing very still
just twitching his nose his enormous
ears
he's just woken up scrub hairs as the
name and plow will have spent the whole
day
hidden in some low scrub
hiding away coming out at night
where they will graze often found on the
roads
because the roads are a little bit more
open there's a bit of disturbance around
next to the roads which offer quite nice
grazing and also
the path of the road offers a very nice
sort of social area and an area for them
to run on
the sounds of the bush start to change
from the daytime
sound to the nighttime sounds this is
probably the time when
no doubt that the cubs or the hyena cubs
went into their den because
june moved off and the other hyenas are
nowhere to be seen and they will be
starting their calls and hopefully the
oklahomans will be up soon to show you
some
action hopefully they'll come in to juma
but we are now
on a leopard search let's see if
ollie or myself who will become
the champion this afternoon
it's nice to compete sometimes
holy city's got no luck it's all about
luck
laura do you want to know what columba
went to chitra i think she may be just
she's gone
looking for tandy you know i think she
she decided she's been waiting in the
same area for long enough
she wants to find out where mom's gone
and she she ventured all the way down to
chitwa the one evening and then
the following day she came all the way
back again we haven't managed to find
her again since then
so maybe she found tandy and they've
gone back over to torchwood
um there are landowners and tortured at
the moment so we're not able to get
across there at the moment
but also with with the rain now
there should be some new tracks around
but uh before
these rains fell the ground after a lot
of rain has fallen
gets very hard and unfortunately a small
leopard like that can be very elusive
you know if you don't find a nice sort
of soft area where potential tracks have
been put down
the animal can just avoid you completely
i mean even if you know where she is and
you try frame up she can be almost
invisible so
that is the reality i'm afraid with
these animals
so this is the time of day when we're
hoping to find them walking in the road
as they start hunting looking for
scrubbers and dakers and impala
but the night time starts to become
where they do their thing
it could be lucky
paula i really don't know what's going
on with tandy where she's at
why she hasn't come back for talamba
really hard to say
i don't want to to put any thoughts in
anyone's minds but
i haven't seen her in three weeks so
i've no idea no idea what's going on
with her
um she might just be enjoying herself in
the east she might have found some food
and is quite happy you know lots of
impala that side maybe she's
eaten quite a few kills getting herself
nice and plump enjoying and not having
to share
knowing that klumbe is just fine by
herself but i'm sure she'll be back to
say hello again
you know the mother's the mother's
instinct
to check on her youngster is strong with
tandy she's done very well i mean how
many cubs
has she successfully reared that we know
of i mean only myself
i know of kuchava uh tamba
and na talamba it's probably more that a
lot of you back home have
know about none that i i can remember
off hand
um i try and keep my mindset onto the
animals that
i've seen it's hard enough to remember
all the names as is
but i know a lot of you have been
following the show for a long time so
you'll know exactly how many
cubs tandy's had
very beautiful cubs indeed
okay so we're coming around the corner
now this is leopard
country leopard country here we oh
sorry and there's a hole in the ground
as well okay well let's go over to
paulie and see what he thinks of the
leopard challenge and see exactly where
about some drummer he is
uncle steve
the challenge is on oh a cable here
thank you ankyl uncle steve you know
what
we need this the child is on
30 minutes left of the shop
and then i'll be the one who finds
like a leopard i'm on my way to
to buffalo swoop damn
and maybe we'll see something drinking
there
maybe a cat maybe giraffe
antelope
scuba steve or maybe we'll see scuba
steve
going out
so i've listened and listened to to the
sounds
that aubry said he had
from the papoons but i wasn't lucky
so that's why i've changed the direction
and then i decided to come to
bethel's week area
oh skewer steve here my friend
oh let's check
maybe we'll be lucky to spot something
here
oh hello skipper steve
i hope we'll be seeing some newborn
babies in the future
in this damn
who knows because you can see it's male
and female
and they're probably mating
and i wonder what is going to be the
name of scuba steve
little one skewed
and scared stewart stewart
oh stuart uncle jim said stewart but
we'll see about that
so we have a lot happening here you
see there this is a grey
heron one of my favorite birds
s-shaped neck i call them
snake herons sometimes because of the
shape
and if you can see the behavior of this
bird it's standing
and that's what the heron does in most
cases they will stand
and then they will they will look for
a prey swimming and then they will
they'll stab it with their peak
just like the black heron if you have
seen a black heron
i'll show it in the book if you see a
black heron
it when it's hot it will open its wings
and stand still there
and then it will make a shade then the
fish or frogs or something will
cause it because they laugh in a shade
so it will
grab it from the shade so on the left we
have the
yellow peeled stock
this guy is is uh forever here these
days
yes and he looks dirty today you know
what happened he was
what are you looking 30 man uh
the pink color is fading now it simply
means he's
slowly getting out of
the breeding season and look check the
behavior of of these two
this one it's submerges its peak
in the water and then while walking
that's how they hunt so
while walking they disturb
the prey
do you see that let's see
and let's hope it will catch something
that would be
amazing
and these guys are migrants and if they
like they can stay
here all year round depends whether they
have
enough food but if they feel like mike
writing they can
and you can see the shade bay
oh it's give us the blowing
his nose thing i'm just checking what's
happening around maybe i'll see
something but it's getting dark now
nothing so i wonder where's uncle steve
now i'm at
uh before zhuk i'm sure he can he can
get that in his comments that i'm in
perhaps who could
slowly and then thoroughly searching for
for a cat a spotted kid
no like yet for this chap right here
oh let me slowly make my way
to the place where i'll find a cat
and i love the breeze
hello yellow pill stock
i wonder how this thin thin thin legs
carry that big body there
this jade
james these things this is a
this you can see it's my it's part of my
earpiece
and this one is part of my mac pack
this is the one this thing that makes us
to communicate with you and hear all
your questions
microphone and earpiece simpler terms
yes
so uh now i won't be looking on the
ground because it's getting dark and i
won't see any tracks
here let's go to the middle
that's the effort
so we'll check from here to to that side
and see whether a cat went in
or went out
it'll be difficult hey
and the birds are making their last
calls of the day
preparing to slip
yes i'm not lucky yet it's
i'm sure uncle steve have something but
let's go to sydney with the lions
too
probably a snake yeah
sorry about that everybody not sure
what's happened uh on the other side
which you are with us still no leopard
though
let's just go have a look at whatever we
had a
a uh red back strike shouting over here
trying to ascertain where the
nice red back shot let's see if you can
hear it
quite often those sounds will be
it's an alarm call from the shrike
trying to indicate maybe there was a
mongoose
maybe there's a snake i can't see it
maybe it's down hidden in the long grass
well
and move on from that sometimes you can
be alerted to leopard by a bird
shouting by bird shouting
but not that time whatever it was
too small to spot spotlight as you can
see is out
the lights are on let's get our lights
going
this is how we're going to find a
leopard all furnaces burning
who are we going to see if we find a
leopard we're looking in an area
where columbus spends a lot of time i
haven't seen her now we haven't seen her
for a few days
and as she moved south as we discussed
it but then came back in again
where she is now we have no idea i've
been checking the
usual haunts but this is also an area
that's
quite regularly frequented by tandy
who we haven't seen as well i said for
quite some time
no doubt they are around somewhere
everybody
and they will turn up just in time
they're having a little bit of a holiday
you see they know we don't have a tv
show for some time so okay cool we'll
just um
go away for a few days just take a few a
couple of weeks off
it's in there right isn't it the film
stars after all a couple weeks a year
can't complain about that can we nah
philip you don't know if my car breaks
will i fix it well it really depends
what breaks
we do have a mechanic that is on site
he's not
permanently working for us but he is a
magician
his name is oppa which is quite
interesting because oppa in afrikaans
means grandfather
and i think he's about the same age as
me uh maybe even younger than me i don't
think opa's older than me that's for
sure
so a young gentleman of course but he's
a magician
we will struggle with things and then
he'll arrive and within five minutes
he's fixed the problem
that's what you get experience in
certain things
knowing exactly what to do
but he generally fixes most of the
mechanical issues
but when it comes to basic stuff most
certainly
i'll sort that out
we just got any hiding in the bushes
there
so for those of you who new to safari
the spotlight is out that the objective
of the spotlight is it reflects the eyes
back
from animals animals have got this
filament or lens on the back of the iris
called
the tipitum lucidum which is designed to
absorb as much light
in the atmosphere as possible to allow
animals to see
when it's dark um not all animals have
it
we don't dranos don't and apes
elephants have a very minor one you
don't really see the reflection
but when you shine it on eyes they shine
back
at you and that's how we spot them
so we're looking for the eyes shining
back and then when we spot them
then often you can know whether it's a
leopard or something
but there's quite a bit of discussion
about it takes a lot of time to
to get your head around what exactly
what animal it is
nina i'm hearing most of it from sammy
but i'm not getting the question at all
not getting at all sammy's saying
something about
someone roaming but i don't i'm not
hearing the rest of what you're saying
to me i'm afraid
sorry about that samuel i'll try and get
your question through and answered for
you
sam you you want to know about gorillas
well it's very hard to say but
um gorillas occur in forested areas very
dense forested areas
uh we don't have any of them down here
but
maybe very long time ago these areas
used to be more forested
and then it is possible yes the gorillas
were around but
i'm not sure if it was ever this far
south we still have gorillas in sort of
the north
in a sort of central africa but none
right now
at the moment so gorillas are more of a
forest animal
not an open savannah specialist samuel
so baboons are probably the closest
relative with us of course
to the apes of the jungle
i hope that answers your question for
you
they were wonderful to see gorillas
wouldn't it it's one of on my bucket
list to go up and see them
but they enjoy very green
wet forested areas down here
it's way too hot for them way too dry
i think it gets quite hot where they are
but it's very humid
that's where they enjoy it in the
tropics
in the jungle the proper forested jungle
of central africa
so when the savannah formed uh ourselves
and baboons were probably the first
sort of creatures to or
of that sort of family to have roamed
out of the forest
and we moved away from our dependency
with
trees gorillas obviously don't spend too
much time in trees they're very big
um but they do spend a little in the
forest they haven't evaded or moved out
to the forest
and that's where they spend their time
okay
well we've come towards joomla watching
whole pan hoping to find something
nothing at the moment this is another
last ditch effort
to see if we can find you a spotted cat
we're going to go back towards
chilipan within cut east western's time
abey you want to see a bush bush baby a
bush baby would make up for no leopard
well i will try and find you a bush baby
um along this riverrun area just on our
left is an area where we often find them
but um that i haven't seen one in some
time
i don't know what they've been up to it
might just be the fact that the trees
are so
dense and we just don't see them moving
around as we do
as much in the winter months we see them
much more clearly
because our spotlight shines so much
further in and i was talking about i
shine before bush babies have got some
of the brightest eyes out here because
they've got such
big eyes and well they reflect back
beautifully
and they've got very big eyes a very big
orangey red
shine that comes back and they're one of
the easiest animals to know immediately
what it is because
well they're in the tree and then they
say whoops and you see them fly like
three four meters away
so they're quite easy animals to
identify but when you start driving
around and you
you see a daca or a steering book the
size of them and the color of their eyes
could quite easily confuse you for a
leopard they often do
takes a lot of time and a bit of
practice to get that down
because we're just not designed to see
at night that's why we invented these
wonderful torches
katie well lepers aren't essentially
going to be attacking us if they were
with this industry just wouldn't work
you know we're not walking at night
leopards at night
on foot probably run away from you
anyway
but essentially wild leopards have a
fear of man
wild lions wild all the wild animals
have a fear of man because
we evolved on their savannah landscape
with them so
if they do if the only time you actually
need to be afraid of a leopard or
worried about it
if it's a sick or injured and then you
need to be very careful and its body
language
will tell you straight away what's going
on and you'll hear it
you'll hear it but there's really if a
leopard wanted to jump in this car and
pull me out there's really nothing i
could do about it
absolutely nothing but while leopards
essentially are pretty dossa
and pretty relaxed to the vehicles once
they're habituated
they're not out to get us we're not on
their list of food items
and we don't walking around at night
because if we walk around
well that's just going to put us in the
time of day when predators
are active well talking about nighttime
predators and searching
oily is still in the search for his
leopard whereabouts is exactly i'm not
sure
but let's go see if he's had any luck
gave up looking for tracks but i'm using
my spotlight to
look and search for for the flesh
then uncle steve what i'd love to see
and what's in my bucket list
is to see is to go and see the
orangutans in the wild i would love to
see that
i've never seen orangutan before live i
only saw it
on tv screen
so i'm not far away from
from the camp because i i made a big
loop
to see whether i'll detect something or
see something or smell something
so on my way to voyatella
at them day
i wanted to chuck check whether we'll
hear the frocks
calling
i love the frogs i love them a lot so we
we're on ir now you can see we are on
black and white
yes because
we have to see within these
thick bushes and this darkness
you can see the the the clouds
all over the sky and
what i want to do there is to switch off
my car
ellie belly can i make a leopard call
uh let me try it uh
i can because we we have the contact
call you remember
we have a territorial caller oh
and then we we have this one
[Laughter]
that's when a female is calling for for
the cops
so what i want us to do is i would love
uh us to to switch off the lights even
the
the presenter light and we'll go with ir
yes this is beautiful
sorry about the lights and i just want
you
all the viewer to to to to to
to close their eyes and listen to the
sounds of the world
these frogs around here
and tell me what
you are feeling i want you to imagine
that you are
just at the back of the vehicle now
so if and also enough to the fc
to link away if they need to but i would
like to have
a minute or minute and a half to keep
quiet and listen to the calls
oh
foreign
[Laughter]
4.
this is magic
i hope and i believe everyone felt as if
he was
just right here in south africa national
park
actually i i feel i can i can spend more
time here
and listen to to the calls because i
love them and i hope
everyone felt the same
this is really blissful this is magic
what must i do now must i leave yes
let me leave
oh
these are the things oh this is that the
things that
uh they make me feel more attached to
the wildlife
listening to the calls of the frogs
the birds
yeah this is magic and it gets emotional
sometimes
did you feel that but i've also felt
emotional
mike want to know uh this rocks they
call
all year round uh
remember mike uh the frocks they are
most
active during the wet season during the
the dresses in the hope they uh
they hibernate i can say that but they
can stay in a place for a while and a
long time
underneath the ground they will hide
themselves there in a place in a
suitable place
and then they will only come out after
the rains or during the rainy season
so they they don't call all year round
that happens during the white season
fresh droppings of the elephant can
smell them
it was so good
oh fortunately i didn't find a
leopard but i've enjoyed the frogs but
for now
let's go to uncle steve and see what he
has
for us
well paulie it's not over yet my friend
do we still have
two minutes or so to find a leopard and
everyone out there knows
i think there's even a hashtag for
last-minute leopards
if there is it there should be but we
unfortunately having difficulty with our
infrared light
so that's why you're seeing i am
possibly
i might not be in color depends on what
filters have been to put on from the
other side but
we don't have a working ir light i don't
know why it is well beyond my capacity
to explain but um bk has tried
everything you can
but for now we are just going to drive
along and see what we can find
last couple of minutes in the show just
going to take a left here
go around quarantine maybe we'll get
someone moving around in the darkness
who knows
it's been a very nice afternoon i'm glad
that the clouds have moved in it doesn't
look like there's any looming rain
right now it might rain at 2 30 again in
the morning
throwing us all into a flurry or should
i say james and so flurry as he ran to
cover all the vehicles
shape really did come down last night
the rain
well the lightning was right on top of
our heads
incredible if you like lightning if you
don't i think it would have been
terrifying
i was quite terrified for a moment seb
he
had a bit of a fright as well he was in
the bathroom at the time when it
happened
can you imagine now he's had to go on
some leave to recover from the
the trauma from uh standing in the
bathroom while lightning
rained around his head
well it has been a wonderful afternoon
with the joomla clan and we have
thoroughly enjoyed it ourselves beacon i
think i've been very lucky we spotted
june
just at the end otherwise we would have
left the due to june clap
the the two mclaren all together but we
managed to follow her back and what a
marvelous afternoon
we had indeed and well james has had a
good afternoon out there with paulie
sydney with his very flat cats sadly
we've lost signal with him
but thank you to all of you for joining
us for another sunset safari
we'll see you again tomorrow morning
nice bright and early for another
sunrise safari
coming to you live from juma and the
mara from myself for the rest of the
team
thank you for your questions comments
we'll see you tomorrow good night